well the shadow Chancellor John
McDonnell lays in Westminster tonight
and joins me now what do you make of the
exit poll John McDonnell well if the if
the seats
if the seat tally comes out that way
it's going to be extremely disappointing
of course it is I'm not sure that seat
tally will shadow the completely the the
exit poll itself but even if it's
anywhere near that yes it is it's really
just extremely disappointing okay and
why is he disappointing I want to put
you something your colleague Barry
Gardner said to me earlier he said that
he felt sorry for the voters that
they've been let down this is democracy
the voters have a clear choice and on
that exit poll they've decided they
don't like the Labour Party very much
and they want to go with Boris Johnson I
think I think the poll itself it looks
as though it was the brexit dominated a
lot of this I think was brexit fatigue
people just wanted it over and done with
and it put labour in a very difficult
position because the vast bulk of our
members supporter and campaign four
remain but large number of Labour MPs
including myself had constituencies that
voted leave so is what it was always
going to be difficult for us to straddle
those positions and that's what's hit us
pretty hard but I think basically it
looks as though all other debate on
other issues so it's been squeezed out
why there's one issue directly and as I
say it wasn't just levers I think I
think also even people in the referendum
might have voted remaining I mean what I
feel sorry for the voters you'd be I'm
sure you will be very familiar with the
term false consciousness you know people
took a decision here not to vote for you
and yes get brexit done and they voted
for the Conservative Party why I felt
sorry for them because although they
might have voted to get brexit done it
doesn't look as though it will get done
I think it will go on for a number of
years and there are still those risks of
no deal brexit on the table as well so
it sounded simple as a slogan but in
practice and reality it's going to take
quite a while before
does get resolved that's the first thing
I and I fear also during that period
we'll have continuing uncertainty and I
also fear that the sort of deal that
might well be arrived at the end will
not be beneficial for the economy or
protect jobs and Livingstone so that's
one issue but also it is about
installing what is I think is generally
seen as possibly the most right-wing
extreme cabinet but we've seen in our
history and it means therefore they will
have if they have a large majority like
this they will have then therefore the
opportunity to introduce some quite
reactionary policies and so there are
there are worries but if there if the
electorate have decided this way that's
democracy and there you have to you have
to respect it but I don't that are you
accepting I don't think well I don't
think it will bring the country together
I think you'll be deeply divided still
have you spoken to the leader do you
think you should stay leader well
obviously we will wait and see what
happens in the morning with all the
results coming out and we'll see what
whether the results actually do match
the exit poll itself exit polls have
been wrong in the past but we'll see and
then appropriate decisions will be made
I'm sure but you know you've been on the
campaign trail for many weeks now you've
been up and down the country you must be
bracing yourself to say goodbye to quite
a few colleagues tonight if if the exit
poll is right and we lose that many
copies I feel for them I really do
because I know how hard they've worked
in Parliament in the interest of the
country
and I also know how hard they've worked
in their own individual constituencies
and if it is anything on this scale we
will have lost some really good MPs and
I I do feel for them of course I do and
if mr. Corbyn you say you're gonna wait
for the results to come in but if he
does go you need a new leader you've
been talked off as an interim one well
decisions will be made appropriately in
the right timescale once we know the
results I'm sure but let me make it
clear I'm not standing for a leader of
the Labour Party I've said that time and
time again either as a temporary or as a
permanent that's not what I want to do
what am i what about you personally even
as Shadow Chancellor you said
in a magazine in TV you said you would
stand down if you lost and lost this
badly
no well as I say once we know the
results themselves that's the time to
make decisions and that that's what
we'll do in the meantime let's watch
these results and I'm hoping that the
seats share will not be as ok
dramatically bad as the poll itself and
I don't think they will but as I say
it's okay Charlotte Chancellor thank you
very much indeed
for talking just